we move on to this changing topics the
mysterious death of American tourists in
the Dominican Republic and the shooting
of Red Sox legend David Ortiz also known
as Big Papi are making some people very
reluctant to travel there as you may
have heard six Americans have died in
the dr in the last year including a
Maryland couple and a Pennsylvania woman
who died within days of each other at
the same resort now the FBI is helping
local law enforcement with the
investigation so how do travelers
protect themselves that is the question
everybody wants to know mark Elwood is
here he's got some answers he's a
contributing editor at Conde Nast
Traveler mark thank you for joining us
coolest no this is enormous
this is a very serious story normally
you're here with some light-hearted
travel tips but this is very serious
people are afraid to go to the dr and to
that you say what i say look at what the
government tells us for the last couple
of years the government has run the
state department has run a travel
advisory system we're at great
destinations 134 for being somewhere
that you should really shouldn't go from
the beginning the dr has been rated to
the most recent travel advisory april 15
stores a to just know it's not a very
good number two is to is much better
than three or four and the government is
saying the government is not telling us
not to go it is saying go but be
cautious right so how do you vet a
destination or a hotel for safety
because this this everything feels so
random in these attacks you and I think
that's I think it I think it is very I
think it is very worrying and very scary
the two things I would do you've got
Google Streetview now yeah I love
checking out a destination on the ground
from home it's like your own sort of
recce sortie mission you can see the
neighborhood before you booked a hotel
if you have already booked a hotel and
you want to know a bit more about the
destination social media gives you a
live snapshot of what regular people are
saying Instagram Twitter Facebook so you
are getting a sense of whether people
who are visiting are as are as worried
as perhaps from a distance we feel it
might be if you've already booked a trip
and you're hearing all this news and
thinking you know what I'm not gonna
risk it yeah what are your options I
understand and I think I understand if
people are nervous the governments that
travel advisory means there's no
requirement for companies to say yes you
can cancel your trip but
but if you call your airline and you say
it's my first trip abroad with my two
little kids I'm really nervous can you
work with me
human beings are much more much more
understanding than the small print might
suggest hotels seem to be a little less
understanding there the trouble spot I
mean I you know I think everyone is
human and I think if you put your case
very well I'd also say there's a great
service that I love called closed circle
it's a new service it's basically like a
personal bodyguard you can download that
onto your phone it tracks you it sends
you alerts of anything that's going on
nearby there's an SOS button and it
costs about the same as travel insurance
so if you want extra security do that
and close circle closed circle CL OS e
circle what's so troubling to me about
what's happened in the DAR you're
talking about in case I think someone
who drank a cocktail at a bar another
one something came out of a minibar I
mean how do you protect yourself against
anything like this I think you know I
think that as I say I think social media
is very helpful because I think you can
get a sense of a place I think you want
to keep your wits about you that's why
it's at a level two it's telling you
this is this is a destination where you
should be you should be a little on the
alert but I think extraordinary things
can happen it's been terrible but I've
heard you say read the local newspaper
why well see I think one of the best if
you're nervous in a destination and you
want to put a bit of a force field
around yourself yeah by a local
newspaper and put it under your arm oh
AC because if you put it under your arm
people can see the local paper yeah and
even if you don't speak the local
language it suggests that you might and
therefore you're less vulnerable suppose
camouflage it got to be exactly the
course Arkell would thank you very much
very good to